kourtney kardashian and travis barker
are ready to say i do
with a source telling e.t the wedding
day is coming soon and revealing how
court's ex scott disick feels about it
i'm just like living life and whatever
happens happens after getting engaged in
a romantic beachfront proposal last
october the source shares the couple is
now looking at dates in the spring and
summer for their wedding adding quote
they want their wedding to speak on
behalf of both their styles with some
sexiness and elegance
i love it and turns out both travis and
courtney are very involved in the
wedding planning process and they're
both super excited but our source notes
the push founder has been leading the
way and fans will be getting an inside
glimpse at how their big day came to be
in court's new reality show with her fam
the kardashians over the last
year we've seen such transformations
from all of us
this is day one but when it comes to
court's ex scott and how he feels about
everything the source explains that he
hasn't entirely come to terms with
court's relationship with the rocker but
he has definitely warmed up to accepting
the fact that courtney is marrying
travis there are moments of jealousy and
animosity but at the end of the day he
wants her to be happy i mean i think you
just gotta
figure out really what's important to
you at the end of the day as for scott's
dating life well he's keeping things
casual but hopes that eventually changes
a source tells et the tv personality is
currently just dating around right now
but he would like to find something
serious in the long run for now scott's
all about their three kids mason
penelope and rain time is ticking baby
we're from new york let's go
from new york which means some of you is
from new york
[Music]
nice ring you see he knows what time it
is the source says scott is healthier
than he's ever been and he's taking this
time to really soak up the time he has
with his kids and really make them his
primary focus scott and courtney are
also prioritizing how they're raising
their kids our source shares that the
ex's co-parenting routine is very well
balanced and things have been cordial
between them i think we've been through
so much in so many things and to hear
her be proud of me means you know a ton
to me and from courtney's ex to travis's
ex sheena mokler seems like everyone is
keeping the peace my children are my
first priority and you know that's one
thing that you know travis and i you
know do agree on it's probably the only
thing we agree on but you know our
children come first and their happiness
e.t spoke with the former miss usa last
month she and travis share two kids 16
year old alabama and 18 year old landon
who shared this video from his dad's
engagement celebration on tick tock
check out the kardashians camera crew in
the
your back i make her my wife i want her
to be the young girl you know the
kardashians are good to my kids you know
that's all that matters to me as a mom
you know as long as they're happy and
then you know that's that's the key
[Music]